[Musique]
mon cas mon moi c'est jean luc il ya
deux ans
[Applaudissements]
jean luc lemoine une question oui une
question super importante aujourd'hui en
plus bonjour je m'appelle myriam la
semaine dernière vous avez montré une
conversation où cyril hanouna comparer
le zizi de camille combal avec un cake
donc je voulais savoir peut-on espérer
les voir bientôt tous les deux dans le
meilleur pâtissier
cette question est tout à fait légitime
et à la menora priori syrie et camille
ne devrait pas participer à cette
émission
mais si bas alors pour ceux qui
n'auraient pas vu la sonarges avait en
effet montré une conversation
le petit prince de la fm et le roi de
tous dressent à regarder juste il faut
mais je vais faire un conseil mode
si vous voulez réussir dans les médias
un privilégié le double boutonnage jouer
sur ses sales secrets double boutonnage
sur le blouson comme pour camille
regarder et pour la chemise comme pour
cyril way
aie aie s'attend à un peu bad boy ça
comment comprendre dans la gueule quand
je pense que j'ai fait toute cette intro
pour passer cette photo merci d'ailleurs
david un internaute qui veulent envoyer
merci d'avis en tout cas pour ceux qui
auraient manqué cette conversation tout
de suite un petit rappel
[Musique]
l'achat d'un portable
c'est comme un cake
[Musique]
elle a bien les gâteaux est ce que vous
les ca comme à marbre et quelque part
c'est chaud j'aimerais que quand les
années coupure ya des conversations sur
wii c'est vrai mais c'est bien vous
départager si vous voulez moi daniel
chopin j'ai vraiment là
mentir mais commence à taper un navire
superior version connaissent un bon de
révéler d'autres conversations entre les
deux génies de ses 8
oui parce qu'on se demandait si pendant
les pubs ne parlait que de la taille de
leurs attributs masculins
eh bien pas du tout il chante aussi
nantiat mois vous allez voir on a
l'impression qu'ils sont connectés en
wifi il chante en même temps et quand il
faut se reconcentrer il se reconcentre
en même temps c'est très impressionnant
[Musique]
d
comment tomber dobelle il est tombé
[Musique]
la braderie on a une forme ou une autre
elle est magnifique
alibert regardez là bas merci viagym
j'ai très en forme la semaine dernière
puisqu'il a fait le début d'émission le
plus what the fuck de l'histoire de la
télévision regarder
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec mon ami
ouais si tu commences faisant un bras de
fer ça c'est l'école michel drucker
champs elysées le plus drôle c'est quand
tu regardes le bras de fer sous un autre
angle
je rappelle que ce affronter le titan du
1er arrondissement
ysora salle par semaine contre le
golgoth de tunis est la vision de salles
par an
[Applaudissements]
un conseil arrête la musique lui bonnart
et mange des frites
tu perds ton temps là c'est dommage car
mathieu aimerait tant impressionné cyril
bon les muscles à c'est pas ça on l'a vu
m'impressionne par son talent ah non
mais sérieusement alors discrètement il
vous allez voir il va essayer de vous
impressionner en parlant de ses
réussites en tant que producteur gros
carton auprès de cyril ça c'est le vende
de l'année et auprès de tout le monde
d'ailleurs vous allez voir si vous savez
pas ce qu'est la solitude
vous allez comprendre notez bien le
regard plein de pitié de thierry moreau
à la fin
[Musique]
à rêver
oui
et
[Musique]
j'ai fait une bonne soirée ça a très
bien marché on dit ah ouais bien sûr oui
bon c'est dur c'est dur n'a pas
heureusement cyril a toujours des
surprises pour son battue chérie par
céder tout ce que le rêve de ma tout
c'est de présenter un prime sur s'est
vite et bien si reed avait prévu ça pour
lui l'autre jour c'est dire que ce sont
des images qui passeront ce soir puisque
quand le direct d'érable sera juste
après et matthieu delormeau qui étaient
là c'est vous qui allez présenter ce
prime ce soir 1 1 quel prix mais je
dirai juste après la pub pardon vous
allez présenter ce prime ce soir quelle
prime le prélat qui va se passer après
masi souris ben non mais je me suis juba
la chi chi c'est vous qui avez présenté
et toujours les mêmes
m
[Musique]
sa mère est morte
karine série qu'on embrassait j'ai une
amie m'a surtout apporté votre ami je
pense qu'elle va apprécier car il fait
rien elle est gentille un bon match lui
fait pas des lancements sais pas car il
faut dire que mathieu et lille et plus
être dans l'est plus dans la
présentation il vise déjà plus au regard
des mois je suis pas fondu
[Applaudissements]
avec pas possible parce que quand vous
avez envisagé au départ
nrj12 ou nt1 d'ici là trouver des
solutions cinéma mémoire septième art ah
oui j'en dis pas non mais n'en dit pas
plus septième à écouter bon les mecs qui
ramènerait un rôle quand j'aurai un mec
donc
[Applaudissements]
hormis garde le père jack daniel's on
vous avait dit à la famille
le mec de doute derrière vous avez vu ce
qu'il a fait quand même avec habib sylla
le problème c'est la sortie de l'extrait
abed a tout raconté du top comme ça tu
serais pas il me dit écoute
à l'occasion on s'est un peu dans le
cinéma tu feras des bourreaux je peux
faire des premiers rhône on me dit c'est
vrai que c'est à dire qu'il est pas mal
dans le cinéma commence à me faire
circuler je veux jouer à la lumière de
nos intimes
et
je suis du sud est trop aimé oui pour
changer les habitudes et parce que j'ai
une surprise à la fin je propose de voir
tout de suite ce qu'on n'aurait pas
voulu voir et entendre cette semaine
ça commence par la révélation du secret
de mathieu vous allez enfin savoir
pourquoi il est toujours cité dans les
chroniqueurs préférés du public
le numéro 11 jours
[Applaudissements]
dominique sadon midi oui très fait quoi
dans la vie rien merci
sur le tournage nouveau prend de plus en
plus
[Musique]
un poste tout cas
la gale mathieu mathieu
[Applaudissements]
guinée
non
allez on passe ya isabelle morini bosc
est venu taper votre porte feuille et
ifs
vous restez avec nous à ce qu'on va se
retrouver lors d'un lancement pour tpm
pc que du kif avec qui ça tombe bien on
fera un défi tous les deux surprise pour
vous également jean-luc c'est la fin des
4 vous avez une très grosse révélation
non je les questions sont pas finies
mais je fais arrêter passer ou non mais
non non vous n'avez jamais cac40 prenant
pas oui oui d'accord mais vous avez une
révélation
ah bon d'accord non non non j'ai dit que
j'avais des surprises parce que à la fin
j'ai mis tout le monde au bistrot on se
retrouve dans un instant sur ce but on
vient
aujourd'hui alors la suite bien sûr
l'attend avec impatience le fil de la
semaine maintenant je vais vous révéler
un secret au enfin téléspectateurs c'est
de plus en plus difficile de crise
laitière carré car les chroniqueurs
cache souvent leurs micros pour que les
entendent pas c'est pas sympa
heureusement il ya isabelle qui est le
cache du micro après avoir parlé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
puisque internet ça sert à rien après
mathieu maman il m'avait dit une
vacherie croirait pas entendu c'était
quoi la vacherie osasuna j'oubliais
c'est vrai qu'il se cherche tout le
temps pas tout le temps les deux crs
bruit s'aiment pas pour tous à commencer
chez vous connaissez depuis combien de
temps les deux sa part 25 ans 25 ans
d'accord et aimerait donc non ça va
aller les douaisiens faites vous plaisir
fait du fort au faible coût la tête de
ma mère c'est dallas elle va trouver le
son vous avez vu isabelle en parler mais
thierry qui fait beaucoup parler ses
camarades même quand il n'est pas là
l'autre jour il ne faisait pas le prime
du ski donc ses camarades on imaginait
sa soirée
mon coeur me frottant les 7 jours qui
suivent au croisic opéré sept jours vers
les maisons ces numéros
[Musique]
pas la loi
des jets d'eau
et même à répondre
c'était trop dur
le portugais portugal voilà la halle est
quelque chose de plus valorisant pour
thierry la semaine hier c'était les
élections de tpm pays et chaque
chroniqueur cherche un slogan de
campagne avec des rimes marchant avec
leur nom et quand titi est jean michel
maire ça donne ça
[Musique]
le match
femmes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les me sauver si vous jean michel ruiz
suis désolé je n'affiche pas sur les
murs dans messages comme comme slogan ça
passe pas alors heureusement il a perdu
aux tirs
jean-michel mais après ils ont cherché
un slogan pour thierry donc une rime
avec moreau je les vois sur michel il
est gentil mais c'est pas jacques
séguéla
[Musique]
le jeune jours
actif y a
[Musique]
thierry moreau
pour interview à l'assaut du jeu serait
toujours derrière
[Applaudissements]
meilleur dans sa catégorie n'avait pas
sa raison s'est laissé dans sa catégorie
candidats la sono embarquée pour une
fois un candidat risque de tenir
allez pour finir et comme ça fait
longtemps gemmayzé ce que seraient les
missions si toi on a alors réalisé
connaissez le principe le jeu ralentit
les images et ça envoie tout le monde au
bistrot
alors jolie vous vous accrochez mois les
musiques et est anormal la mongolie oui
les mongols oui mais les murs mais
beaucoup mongolie comment et en plus ces
cartes ne m'atterre d'audience 3
millions 900 mille alors ça venir à
m'aider oui allô mairie mon métier
l faut qu'ils mettent fruits non
vraiment je suis le premier à parler je
delà du débat il est 15 heures
les
m
watching you me and you what
jérémy menez mise irait me roy keane et
me gérer mais de quoi vivre padma
samatan moteur
et ça c'est rien c'est folie marais sera
toi tu j'aime tout le monde alors c'est
une super épreuve ça n'a aucun intérêt
c'est resté 32 35 milles devant devant
de personnes de mou seras poteau 15 bien
deux heures shooter
depuis 19h
et à m sila crowning doit revenir je
vends une augmentation
[Applaudissements]